The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, let's get underway.
Yeah, this thing is on.
Any burning questions
from last time?
Any debate points you really had
to make, and didn't get made?
OK.
Today we're talking
about path dependence.
Sorry.
You were raising your
hand, or was that a wave?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I didn't say much yesterday,
but on the note of labor and--
a lot of times I'm on the
labor side of things yesterday,
or at least a bit of it.
And people were talking about
how providing, let's say,
workers' rights, union rights,
et cetera, things like that,
would impede the freedom
of the working process.
And I feel that almost every
industrialized country nowadays
has gone through this process
of horrible workers' rights
to a system more like
we have now, let's say.
China's going through what we
did 100 years ago currently,
with some of their whole
stuff, with workers working
way too long shifts, and
there being not much safety
on chemicals, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You're
just arguing that Sutherland was
on the wrong side of history.
Yes?
And so what we've come to is
where we should have come?
AUDIENCE: Kind of--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Kind of--
OK.
But you could understand
how, circa 1935--
wasn't obvious which was
the right side of history.
It is now, of course.
AUDIENCE: You could
say hindsight's 2020,
but if someone's
working 10 hours a day
in highly dangerous
conditions, you
might say that's not
kosher then either.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The
right side of the room
would have replied, and
maybe will reply, that--
take another job, if
you don't like it.
Become an investment banker.
Come on.
AUDIENCE: There are high
impedances to doing [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: There are.
There are.
Good set of points-- didn't
mean to put you down.
One the problems with doing
that case is we sort of
know how it worked
out after that.
We know that Cardozo
and the whole
you got to allow more
regulation of the market
to make-- for a variety
of reasons, triumphed.
But I'm not enough
of a determinist
to think that was inevitable.
It happened, and it
happened lots of places.
AUDIENCE: It took a long
time for that to happen.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It did.
It did.
Anything else on last time?
OK.
What I want to do today is
talk about path dependence.
And let me just do
a little visual.
We always like to think
that choices get made,
you look at the
alternatives, and the choices
are the obvious
rational choices.
So we use the
energy systems that
make the most sense to use.
And let me just
anecdotally suggest
that can't be right, just that
statement that, at any point
in time, we're obviously
using the systems that
are the, technically, or
even economically, best.
The reason is, if you look
across rich countries,
they make different choices with
the same available technology,
the same rough
standards of living.
So here's rush hour in
Copenhagen. The city's designed
for bicycling.
Lots of people use bicycles.
You got similar
photos from Amsterdam.
I've got friends who
have moved to Amsterdam.
They never drive.
They bicycle every place.
It's just a different
system of urban design.
We've got bicycles.
We could have gone
that direction.
There's a Japanese
high-speed train.
They've had high-speed
trains for a long time.
We don't really have any.
There are a bunch
of them in Europe.
We've decided not to.
Oh, that's the thing
we saw earlier.
That's that diagram for
France that's shorthand for,
and they decided to use
a lot of nuclear power--
more than anybody
else decided to do.
Everybody had
those technologies.
Certainly, everybody
had bicycles and people
can build trains.
Different countries
made different choices.
And just to gild the lily,
that's the Paris subway system.
I have a sister who lives
in Munich, who occasionally
visits us and talks about our
third-world subway system.
And I point out,
that's really an insult
to places like Mexico City
that have pretty decent subway
systems.
But Paris and London--
I couldn't find a great
London picture-- have clearly
made much greater investments
in that energy using technology
than we have.
That's a trolley in Munich.
There are a lot of them.
They're fast.
They're efficient.
They're everywhere.
That is a Swiss
railway schedule.
That's, how do you get
from the Zurich airport
to Davos, where the World
Economic Forum is held?
And I've actually done this.
Those trains arrive
on the minute.
There is no, gee, I wonder
when the train's coming.
The train is due at 3:41.
The train is there at 3:41,
unless something terrible
has happened.
So that's lots of
very convenient ways
you can get from
the Zurich airport
to this little village in
the mountains in a couple
hours very reliably.
There's equivalent operations
elsewhere in Europe,
but the Swiss really
stand out in terms
of having invested in a very
efficient, very reliable system
of rail transport from
little towns to little towns.
And that's a solar
field in Germany,
where the Germans--
again, same technology
we have-- have decided to put a
lot of money into solar power.
So it can't be the
case that, once you
know the level of
income and once
the available technologies,
the choices follow.
The processes must be
different from that,
from just rational calculation.
At the very least, that
story's incomplete, right?
Because what determines what
are the technologies available?
What determines where the
innovation dollars go?
What determines
whether you spend
money making automobiles
more efficient
or nuclear power
plants more efficient?
So at the very least, the
set of technologies available
isn't given from heaven, and
the choices aren't necessarily
done on a spreadsheet--
because if they
were done on a spreadsheet,
lots of countries
would make very similar choices.
And in fact, we see
lots of rich countries
making very different choices.
We'll talk a lot about this,
but people make choices.
It's very standard to say
the market makes choices.
People make choices in
their individual demands.
collective decision making
in politics.
Those choices reflect a lot of
things, as we'll talk about,
but countries have
different cultures,
countries have
different histories,
countries make
different choices.
Besides those examples-- it's
really a fascinating historical
exercise-- if you look at
Chinese technology circa 1500
or 1600 AD, there are
a number of areas--
including, in particular,
ships, in which China
is far ahead of the West--
China did not exploit
those advantages,
for a variety of reasons--
cultural reasons, primarily.
If you think about the
cultural decision in Denmark
and in Holland to
retain reliance
on bicycles as a
main urban transport,
as opposed to, say, China
where, years ago, you
would go to a Chinese city-- you
would see hordes of bicycles.
Now you see hordes
of cars not moving.
But China switched.
Denmark didn't.
Holland didn't-- chose not to.
So what I want to
talk about is not
that whole set of complexities
affecting decisions,
because it is interesting--
and we'll spend a lot of time
on it as we go forward.
I want to just
talk about history
and the influence of history--
three different versions
of path dependence--
not all of them necessarily
deserving the name,
but all of them having to do
with the way history matters.
So the first one is
many energy systems
involved durable capital.
In fact, durable
capital's important.
Now, just because I
love to pull pictures,
there's the railroad system.
There are tracks laid
down in the 1860s that
are still in use.
There's a really particularly
ugly power plant.
I think that one was
built in the 1920s,
but there is a power plant
in Salem, Massachusetts
that was first built in 1951,
that is still operating.
Half of it's shut down.
Half of it's still operating.
There are power lines.
They last a long time.
There's an oil refinery.
They also last a
pretty long time.
There's the highway system.
If it weren't for
heavy trucks, I'm told,
highways would be
essentially eternal.
Cars don't damage highways.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I'm from
Chicago, and we did a lot of
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That'll do it.
Yeah.
Time will do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I went to
California for the first time
last year, and I was amazed
at how their roads didn't
have cracks in them.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, all you have to do
is drive north from
Illinois into Wisconsin.
Wisconsin has decent roads.
AUDIENCE: They do.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Part of this is money.
AUDIENCE: Illinois is
state-funded roads,
but Wisconsin's
federally funded roads.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, there's a mixture.
Illinois is also, let us
say, not the best-run state
in the union, historically.
For those of you who--
well, Rod Blagojevich is
just the latest in a--
I'm from Illinois originally,
so I sympathize, but oh
my gosh-- what a history.
Anyway, yes, roads
get damaged by other--
things other than traffic.
And among things that
last a long time,
that's Los Angeles, a
snap of Los Angeles.
When you lay out a city, that
layout lasts a long time.
And old buildings like that one,
that was first built in 1916
and is still going
strong, last a long time.
Now, I want to be a little
clearer here about how
durability matters, because the
natural thing to say is, yeah,
but those are all sunk costs.
What's it matter?
You build a railroad--
that money's gone.
You can walk away,
do something else.
Well, the fact is you're usually
replacing something that's
capital-intensive with something
else that's capital-intensive.
And that fact by itself
makes it difficult to change.
I want to walk through a
little bit of discounting,
some of which you
have probably seen.
But let me just walk through
a little bit of analysis
of a hypothetical plant.
We're thinking of replacing
a coal-fired power plant.
It produces Q units
of output per year.
The variable cost is
v. It costs F to build.
It'll last T years.
The interest rate's r.
We're considering replacing
it with a new plant.
Let's say it's more efficient--
has variable cost v star,
cost F star to build.
It'll also last 2 years,
just to keep things simple.
When do you scrap the old plant,
replace it with the new plant?
Well, I'm going to do--
clears that up?
I'm going to use continuous
compounding, because I'm lazy.
How many of you have seen this
before, continuous compounding?
OK, most of you haven't,
so I will walk slowly.
If you say we're going to
invest $1 today and we're going
to ask, what happens in--
what's it worth in T years,
and the interest's r, then,
if you compounded annually,
that becomes 1 plus r to the
T. If you compounded N times
a year-- well, the interest
rate is divided by N--
1 plus r/N, now to the NT.
So I'm compounding
it more often.
So if it's 12% a year, then $1
today is worth $1.12 in a year.
If it's compounded
monthly, then it's
1.01 to the 12, which is going
to be pretty close, but not
quite the same as--
if you take the limit,
this becomes e to the rT.
And the slide-- well,
the slide gets you there,
asking now, what's $1
in T years worth today?
So if you put $1 here at time T,
that would be e to the minus rT
today.
I use continuous
compounding a lot,
because keeping track of whether
things happen at the beginning
or end of periods is tiresome.
And continuous compounding
works pretty well
compared to daily,
monthly, weekly
for interest rates at matter.
OK, is the problem clear?
Is this limiting exercise
reasonably clear?
Questions, reactions,
stunned silence?
OK.
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: We've already
built the first plant?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: We
built the first plant.
We have it.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And you're going
to tell me that F is
irrelevant, and you're right.
But comes now the second plant.
So I want to ask--
I want to look at the capital
cost per unit of output.
You sometimes do
this-- sometimes
called levelized cost.
But let me define it like this.
Suppose the capital cost per
unit of output is c star.
What's that mean?
Well, if that's the
cost per unit of output,
and I produce Q
units per period,
then, if I discount
that capital cost,
I ought to get the amount
of the capital investment.
So that's my
definition of c star.
There would be a c up here
too, if I went through it,
but that's-- as you
say, that's sunk.
That's sunk.
But I'm interested now in--
because this isn't sunk.
If I build my coal-fired-- my
more efficient coal-fired power
plant costs me F star,
then that gives me--
what's the total cost
per unit of output?
I go out to the end
of the plant's life.
I look at output.
I say, if that's the cost--
if c star is the cost
per unit of output,
then the discounted
value of all those costs
must equal the
initial investment.
That's this simple
expression over there.
Good so far?
Comment, question?
So people do this, for instance,
if you think about how people
calculate-- this is not the
best calculation in the world,
but if you ask, what's
the cost of electricity
from a solar plant,
and you get a number
in cents per kilowatt hour,
this is how you do it,
because the cost of solar
power is almost exclusively
an upfront fixed cost.
And so you look at
the life of the plant.
You look at the
output over that life.
You ask, what cost per
kilowatt hour discounts back
to the original
cost of the plant?
And that gives you a
cost per kilowatt hour
from a solar power plant.
OK?
That's how you do it.
You're very quiet.
I don't think this
is hard, but I'm not
sure it's quite this easy.
So are you all on board?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There's
a lot of uncertainy
in all those numbers, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
In life, yes.
In my story, no.
This is economics, so we
assume God-like powers.
And I know these numbers.
But in real life,
of course, you'd
want to react-- you'd want
to deal with risk issues.
But this is a
straightforward replacement.
So obviously, these
are obvious properties,
if you think about
it for a minute.
You basically solve this
equation for c star,
and you can see, as e to
the minus rT vanishes, you
get what you'd expect--
fixed cost divided
by output made into a flow
with the interest rate.
Now, forget F. The
decision to replace
turns on this comparison--
turns on a comparison of
the total cost of output
from the new plant
with the variable cost
of output from the old plant.
That's the point.
The cost of the old
plant sunk-- doesn't
matter whether I
got it as a gift
or whether it was ridiculously
expensive to build.
It's gone.
So what I care about is
the cost of the old plant.
If my plant is a coal-fired
generating plant,
an awful lot--
and I'm going to replace it with
a new, cleaner, more efficient
coal-fired generating
plant, v star
is going to be small
relative to c star.
v is going to be small relative
to the original capital cost.
That doesn't matter.
Fuel is cheap for a
coal-fired power plant.
The plant's expensive.
So to replace it, I got to say--
putting everything
else to one side,
I got to say, how
does the running cost
of this old
inefficient dog compare
with the total cost of this
bright, shiny, new, high-tech,
very expensive to build,
cheap to operate plant?
That gets you stuff
lasting for a long time.
Clear?
If it's capital-intensive,
you're comparing variable cost
with total cost.
And even if this is
a much better plant,
even if v star is much below
v, and c star isn't bad--
first of all, it doesn't
matter how it compares
with the old capital cost.
That's gone.
What matters is, what is it--
how does total cost compare
with the operating cost?
So why exactly do we have
vibrating PowerPoint?
I don't know.
If you think about other
kinds of investments
that might be made--
and we'll come to this when
we talk about big systems--
institutions, know
how, policies tend
to come from
upfront investments.
They tend to last a long time.
So if you think about
switching technology,
you will think about retraining
a workforce, building a--
building technological
knowledge, and so forth.
Those are systems that
are very long-lived,
and are all up front.
There's Salem Harbor
right there, still--
it's coal-fired, and in fact,
it actually burns a little oil.
You don't see much oil, but
it burns a little bit of oil
and burns some gas.
But it began as coal-fired--
1951-- still going.
Part of it shut
down in December.
Part of it shuts down in 2014.
You remember that
graph from early on,
but the point I make
is all these coal
fired plants are cheap to run.
They may be very inefficient,
but they are cheap to run.
So they last a long time.
They have a high ratio
of capital cost per unit
to variable cost.
One kind of side point--
if you follow
environmental debates,
you will hear that
lots of coal plants,
in fact, will be shut down
for environmental reasons
in the next few years,
and you will hear numbers
on the incredible costs
of replacing those plants.
The point is those
plants eventually die.
Even Salem Harbor
eventually dies.
The economic cost of replacement
isn't the upfront cost.
It's the discounted
cost of replacing
now versus replacing in x
years, whatever x happens to be.
So when you hear the entire
Midwest is going to go broke
because they're
replacing power plants,
they're replacing them earlier.
So you got to know
how much earlier.
So I have to tell you one
other aspect of history that
matters here, and that's
the Clean Air Act.
Those of you with
phenomenal memories
will recall that, when we talked
about the American coal, rather
than Saudi oil discussion, we
talked about the Clean Air Act.
And I mentioned that
the architecture
has states responsible
for meeting air quality
standards and EPA responsible
for setting standards for
new electric generating plants.
So EPA starts up in here,
tightens standards in there,
tightens them later on.
But there are no standards
for these plants,
for all those plants
built earlier.
Complying with EPA
standards is expensive--
depends on the plant,
depends on the standard,
but it adds to cost.
So now you're replacing an
old plant that may be filthy,
dirty with a new plant that has
to meet new source performance
standards.
You can see why the law did it--
why Congress did that,
because it's cheaper
normally to design a
new plant to be clean
than to clean up an old plant.
We'll talk about reasons later
on, but that sort of makes
sense.
But what it means is
building a new plant
is more expensive than
maintaining an old-- even
more expensive than
maintaining an old plant.
So one reason all these
old dogs are still alive
is because they would
have to be replaced
by plants that would be cleaner,
more efficient, and more
expensive.
There is an interesting question
that I won't bore you with--
is what can you do to an old
plant by way of repowering,
changing the equipment, and
modernizing it before it
becomes a new plant, for
purposes of the law--
a question that has
no answer, that I once
spent four months of my life
trying to write a rule on.
OK, is this all clear--
semi-clear?
Questions, comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to ask you--
so given [INAUDIBLE] forgetting
about any environmental
standards that probably will add
to that or whatever EPA rules
you may have, wouldn't you
expect the environemtal cost
at some point to start
increasing, just because--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --your machines are
so old that you can't even
find replacements for what
you have and stuff like that?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And that's when,
putting environmental
considerations aside--
and you would also expect the
performance of new plants,
in terms of both capital and
variable cost, to get better.
At some point, those curves
cross, and you replace.
Or I gave it a finite lifetime.
At some point, the thing
just can't be maintained,
one way or another--
either, for some reason,
it falls apart at your T, or
the costs just keep rising
and you say, this is an old dog.
There are other issues.
One reason Salem Harbor
is still going is,
for stability reasons, they
need to have power injected
into the system around
there, and there's
no obvious other way to do it.
In fact, they're going to,
I think, do some repowering
and do some gas generation.
But anyway, yeah,
there comes a point--
I just had the cost constant.
What happens in life is
that variable cost rises.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How does the
licensing work with this?
Because I know at
some power plants
you have to be licensed
to run, so couldn't you
say they have a 60-year
license, and you're
pretty sure they're going
to replace that anyway.
[INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Nuclear plants in the US
were originally given--
I think it was 40-year licenses.
And they have the ability
to apply for extensions.
I don't believe any
other power plants
have licenses of that sort.
The reason for the
nuclear license is--
I think is that the
federal government limits
the liability of
nuclear plant owners,
and in exchange for
that limit of liability,
wants to make sure the
plants are OK to go on.
But they can apply
for extensions
for another 20 years.
And at that point, they're done.
And that's an engineering
estimate at the start
that we're pretty
sure it'll go 40.
We don't know if
it can go longer.
Let's take another
look at it at 40.
Coal-fired plants don't
have this sort of buildup
of radiation problem.
Other plants don't,
so I don't think
they tend to have
time-limited licenses.
I think some private
hydroelectric facilities
had state limited licenses,
but it can happen.
Yeah.
Anything else at all?
OK.
Let me talk about a second way.
So here's the first way
that history matters.
History can matter just
because of capital intensity.
Your replacement technology's
capital-intensive.
You're comparing it
with a technology
that has low variable costs.
A second way is a
little more subtle,
and it has to do with
the political process.
And that is, just as
a matter of fact--
I don't know there's
an elegant theory here,
but as a matter of
fact, political systems
don't make big policy
changes easily.
They do, but they
don't make them easily,
because they can
be very disruptive.
So once you've gone down
a particular policy path,
it becomes--
the system tends to freeze.
The US system in particular
is prone to that,
because if you think about--
it's more true now
than it used to be--
you think about the need to
have 60 votes in the Senate
to get anything done
at all, a big change
is hard to get 60 votes for
in the absence of a crisis.
Little changes--
this and that-- sure.
Fine tuning-- sure.
But big structural changes the
system just doesn't want to do.
Think about the Clean Air Act.
I've described a couple
of issues with it.
One is the way standards are
set-- the one I just described,
the new source
performance standards.
These problems have been
known since the act was
passed in 1970.
They've been discussed.
Remedies have been proposed.
That architecture hasn't moved.
Why?
Because you've got a
bureaucracy in place,
you've got states
relating to it,
you've got a whole
machinery going,
and you have uncertainty as to
how alternatives would work.
So absent a crisis, that's
not going to change.
Agricultural price supports--
why do we still do this?
Why does the European
Union spend so much money
supporting European farmers?
Well, a policy's in place.
Their interest's in
place, their votes.
It's a reinforcing system--
and because there's a
fear of radical change.
So every so often we debate
our agricultural program,
which benefits 1%, 2%,
3% of the population--
maybe as much as 5%, depending
on how you do your arithmetic.
And we spend a lot
of money on it.
Similarly, we
subsidize oil drilling.
We treat oil companies and
oil exploration in a tax--
in a favorable way from
the point of view of taxes.
Why do we do that?
Well, there are a
whole set of reasons,
but the fact is it's not only
that we don't abolish it--
we also don't make
it more generous.
We all talk about
more US oil drilling,
but the tax system
as it affects oil
has been in place since,
I think, the early '50s.
Big policy changes
just don't get made.
We pass energy bills every
few years, but that one
doesn't get touched much.
Oh yeah, and you will recall
the pre-World War 1 London
electricity system from
last time-- crazy system--
crazy, crazy, crazy.
It really took
close to a crisis.
It took World War 1 to cause
them to say, look, we know
local control is important.
We know it's dangerous to
fundamentally restructure
the electricity
system, but come on.
And they did it.
They, in fact, have
done that twice.
Actually, I think they did that
in the '20s, but in any case,
that was just the nutty
system that persisted.
It persisted.
Big policy changes
don't get made.
We assigned the piece
on health care reform
to illustrate this--
the New Yorker piece,
which I hope you
read, because it was very
readable, and interesting,
and relevant to the
current health care
debate-- if not
particularly to this course.
I will refresh
your recollection.
He argues that everybody,
when contemplating health
care reform, has a tendency
to take a blank piece of paper
and write down some
sort of ideal system.
But if you look at health care,
just like you look at energy,
different countries
made different choices.
Yeah, everybody but the US
among the rich countries
has universal health care, but
no two systems are the same.
No two systems are the same.
I thought the English
example, the UK example
was the most interesting.
They moved to
complete government--
government-run,
government-owned,
government-funded system in 1945
without an eye being batted.
And the reason was they had
to take over the health care
system during World War 2.
They had massive
movements of people.
They had massive casualties.
The government took over a
lot of things in this country,
but it didn't take over
the health care system.
We didn't have that
set of problems.
It took over automobile
companies, and steel companies,
and aircraft companies, but it
didn't take over health care.
It did in the UK.
So after the war,
when they decided,
gee, wouldn't it be good to
have universal health care,
well, they basically
already had it.
So they just needed
to write it up
and say, yeah, the government's
been running the health care
system since 1939.
It's now 1945.
I guess we'll just
keep this system--
sounded like a
huge policy change.
They moved to the
National Health Service,
they moved to universal health
care, but they already had it--
tiny policy change, because--
you going to make a
huge change in 1945?
France was defeated.
They didn't have this kind of
government-run system in 1945.
They look back to the way
they provided health care
before World War 2.
That was something they
could use as a base
and make changes from
to make it universal,
and that's what they did.
They're a set of regional funds.
The Swiss system is interesting.
Switzerland had only
private insurance.
You go buy insurer.
So when the Swiss
decided they were
going to have universal
health care, what did they do?
They said, OK, A, everybody
has to buy insurance, and B,
we'll subsidize insurance
for poor people--
tiny change-- no
big argument about,
let's make a huge change,
let's do a single payer
system like the British,
let's use regional funds
like the French.
No.
Why would you do that?
The system tends to
move incrementally.
The policy system
moves incrementally,
because big policy
changes tend to have
unforeseen consequences.
And if you can
get where you want
to go without running that
risk, policy systems do--
hence, history has consequences.
The US case, you must--
well, maybe you don't know this.
Why do most Americans get health
care through their employers?
They didn't in Switzerland.
They certainly
didn't in the UK--
French case only if you
had a large employer.
This was because,
during World War 2,
among other things, the
government fixed wages.
The economy was
running quite hot.
There was a lot of
demand for labor,
and they were afraid that,
if we didn't control wages,
we'd have inflation.
We had inflation, but
really rapid inflation--
so during World War 2,
they controlled wages.
So employers
competed for workers
by subsidizing health
insurance, which was a way
to get around wage controls.
I don't know the political story
about why that subsidy wasn't
counted as income,
but it wasn't counted
as income for tax purposes.
Therefore, we have
employer-provided health
insurance in this
country, because
of that accident of history.
Therefore, when you do health
care reform in Massachusetts,
as in 2009-- and for that
matter, in the federal system--
we built on employer-provided
health care.
Is that an obviously
good thing to do?
No.
Most people think
it's a mistake.
Most economists think it's a
mistake, that having that tax
deduction distorts decisions.
It makes it cheaper
for employers
to give you income in the
form of health insurance
and to give you
income in other ways.
That's distorting the
compensation decision.
But we have it.
We've had it since the '40s.
Changing it would be
disruptive, so the system
doesn't change it.
So this is the second reason
why history casts a long shadow.
The nice illustrations
for health
care, but the point is the same.
Once you set up a policy regime
now, there are costs of change,
so you will tend--
the system will tend,
except in the case
of crisis, when--
God knows-- but except
in the case of crisis,
the system will tend
to use a prior regime
as a point of departure.
Health care reform in the
US was controversial enough.
Can you imagine what would
have happened if the Obama
administration or
anybody else had said,
OK, we're not going to
get health insurance
through your employer anymore--
we're going to move
to the UK system,
where the government
owns all the hospitals,
and hires all the
doctors and nurses,
and manages health care?
We know it'll work.
They do it in the UK.
Could that have
gotten four votes?
Could a move to
employer-provided health
insurance have gotten three
votes in parliament in the UK?
No.
It would have been
disruptive in either case.
So the system doesn't do it.
So once you go down
a road, it becomes
hard to change the policy
regime that supports it.
Third way-- history matters.
And this is the most
interesting, in a way.
Those were fun,
but this is the--
what's his name-- Unruh article.
He's a little bit
hysterical, and I'll
try to make some
points about that--
and Mahoney, if you can possibly
read sociological theory.
The argument is that, in a lot
of cases, what really makes
path dependence is choices
made that are somewhat
arbitrary that then
puts you on a path that
involves positive interactions
that keep you on the path.
Health insurance isn't quite
a great illustration of that.
It's not bad.
So you have this chance
event in the US that puts you
on a path of employer-provided
health insurance, that then
leads to a set of institutions
being created around it,
tax code created around it,
benefits systems created
around it.
Even forgetting about the
fact that you wouldn't
want to risk the policy
change in Washington,
it would be difficult for the
rest of the system to change.
So Mahoney talks about not
inevitable choices that then
make later choices inevitable.
A classic example of
this kind of interaction
is the keyboards I
assume most of us use,
the QWERTY keyboards.
This design was
originally chosen
because, for
mechanical typewriters,
you wanted to keep keys that
were frequently used together
far apart, because otherwise,
they jam as they came forward.
Has anybody ever typed on a
mechanical typewriter here?
OK, a few-- all right,
this is good for you.
Yeah.
So that was a perfectly
good reason to do it.
Some say it is inferior
to other keyboard designs,
but the fact is,
even if it wasn't--
and the evidence, as I
see it, on this is mixed.
There's been a debate.
Even if it wasn't, think
about what happens.
You begin to have people
who learn to type this way.
You begin to have typing
teachers who learn to teach you
how to type this way.
When the computer
came, when PCs came,
people said, ah, this is
the end of this design.
People can get more
efficient keyboards.
We don't all have to
use the same keyboard.
You can buy a--
used to be able to buy a
Dvorak keyboard for those who
thought it was more efficient.
You can teach yourself to
type this more efficient way
and plug it in.
Well, as far as I
know, almost nobody
did that, because it apparently
isn't more efficient.
So we still use this old
design, because once you've
got the educational
process, once you've
got the standardization
process, if there isn't
a compelling reason
to change, there
are reasons not to change.
You'd have to redo
the instruction books,
you'd have to reteach the
teachers, et cetera, et cetera.
So if you're going to
teach people to type,
it makes sense to do
it one way, and this
is a perfectly good way.
An example I think is better
is Swiss watch making.
Why is watchmaking
a Swiss thing?
The historical story
you get is Swiss farmers
had craft ability, and in the
wintertime in Switzerland,
you don't get out
much in the fields.
So there was a market
for stuff you could do
in the house in the wintertime.
And then, over time,
you begin to get this--
you develop expertise in design.
You develop expertise
in construction.
You start to build
educational institutions
to train a workforce.
You start up a
new watch company.
You can draw on skilled labor.
All of a sudden, you have
computation for people.
You have design computation.
And the Swiss are
tough to dislodge--
training, distribution
channels, design expertise.
But the key thing is the initial
location was pretty arbitrary.
Danish farmers are
inside in the winter too.
It's cold.
Norwegian farmers are
inside during the winter--
Swedish farmers-- it's
cold a lot of places,
and you don't get out.
New Hampshire is
cold in the winter.
Why Switzerland?
Well, no really good story
for why Switzerland starts,
but pretty good-- pretty easy
to see why Switzerland persists.
There all these economies,
all these interactions
that, once you're going down
the road, give you an advantage.
You say, OK, Danish
farmers-- that's fabulous.
They're inside
during the winter.
I'm going to do
watchmaking in Denmark.
Where are the skilled workers
that I can get in Switzerland?
Where the access to
distribution channels?
Where is the foot
traffic of watch buyers
in downtown Zurich?
Where are the design people
I can get in Switzerland?
It's hard.
Starting green field
without all that expertise,
and distribution, and
everything is difficult.
At day 1, it wouldn't
have been hard--
hard for the Swiss.
Would have been
hard for the Danish.
But Swiss did it, and
once they'd done it,
you get path dependence.
They become hard to dislodge.
So there are a lot of
examples of this in energy,
where institutions
and physical systems--
institutions include things
like training, and education,
and policy, and all
of these things--
interact.
Unruh has a good
set of examples,
but I will say he's
a little hysterical.
Once the transformer was
invented, it was over for DC.
Once you could
transmit alternating
current at high voltage
without losses--
with low losses
over long distance,
DC was not in the game.
There are also a variety
of other reasons.
And the notion
that electric cars
were viable, rather
than gasoline cars--
not so much.
They used lead acid
batteries and--
anyway, he's got good
stories, but if you think
about gasoline automobiles--
this is his picture, and he
misses a little bit here.
He talks about
positive feedbacks
among demand, the gasoline
tax, and the road network.
And that's true,
but if you think
about the automobile in the US,
that's only part of the story.
You build up manufacturing
expertise in Detroit.
Think 1900 and walk forward.
You build up all the things that
made Switzerland a good place
to make watches made Detroit a
good place to make automobiles.
It could have been St. Louis.
It could have been Chicago.
It was Detroit.
You began to get an
accumulation of skilled workers.
You got design.
You got capital.
You got a legal structure.
So all of a sudden, you
had Detroit being very good
at making automobiles.
It was a policy decision
in a number of states,
and then at the federal
level that a road network
would be a good thing to do.
So you began to develop a
set of interests there too.
You have jobs here making cars.
You've got jobs making roads.
You've got companies
that pave roads.
that build cars.
You've got institutional
structures.
Then you have a dynamic that
says, through the gasoline tax,
we will--
the more we drive, the
more gasoline tax we get,
the more we put into
building the road network,
the better the road network,
the better it is to drive.
And within all of this--
notice acculturation and
adaptive preferences--
we learn that we can't
live without a car.
People in the 19th
century, it turned out,
had perfectly nice, happy
lives and never owned a car.
So it is possible
for human beings
to live in cities, perfectly,
happily without owning cars.
But we don't believe it,
unless you're from New York.
Most Americans just
can't imagine it.
This is acculturation
and adaptive preferences.
We're with the things
so long it becomes
part of how we think the
good life is defined,
what we think you need.
The institution over
here, the government,
is built-- you've got the
Department of Motor Vehicles,
for heaven's sakes, in every
state with lots of jobs.
You've got a lot of people
invested in this system.
The more you drive, the more
you get tax collection, the more
you build the road
network, the more driving,
the more you need more roads.
The system feeds.
You also have people
invested in doing
R&D. You have people invested
in education and training.
So there's a whole
network of people
who train auto repair people.
Society of Automotive
Engineers gets built.
You have a lot of
jobs in this system--
not necessarily easy to
move, as Detroit has found.
When things go bad
for automobiles,
there's a lot of
political howling.
You have the road network.
It lasts a long time,
just as a physical object.
And it's there for cars.
So once you've built
it, you naturally
want to use automobiles.
The culture adapts.
How do we think of ourselves?
We think of ourselves
as people who
drive in convertibles
with the top
down on beautiful country roads.
No, but if you watch
enough commercials--
particularly if you
watch sporting events--
you see so many car
commercials that involve people
driving happily down the road.
This is how you live.
You also have a policy
regime that comes
to support the whole system.
It's an important
part of the economy.
part of the country.
The political system,
absent some good reason,
is not going to suddenly
turn against the people who
build roads, the
people who drive cars,
and the people who build cars.
And again, the gas tax--
you say, well, when new
technologies come along,
of course, companies
will switch.
Well, one of the things-- and
we'll come back to this when we
talk about corporate
decision making--
companies tend to focus--
as this blurb says, tend
to focus on getting better
at what they're good at.
So rather than taking
dangerous leaps--
so you remember Palm
and the PalmPilot?
That didn't go so well.
Blackberry hasn't
quite adjusted.
General Motors took a
long time to turn around.
There are lots of other
examples of companies
that were really
good at something
and stuck with it too long.
So you tend not to get the
companies that are big players
in a system like this--
any system like this--
to be the ones that
drive the change.
And then finally--
I love this phrase--
I'm not sure I understand
it, but I love it--
historically derived subjective
modeling of the issues.
The point he makes--
Unruh makes is that, when
you're embedded long enough
in any system that has
an impact on your life,
it colors how you
think about the world--
just does, necessarily does.
In the 19th century,
horses mattered.
People would think about
the world in a different way
than they do when cars matter.
A system that's-- in which you
are deeply embedded will affect
how you think, typically in
a way that says more of that
would be good-- not always,
but it will affect it.
Economics textbooks tend to
assume, for simplicity, that we
are born with our preferences.
It's probably not a great
shock to you to know--
and probably you've known all
along-- that's just wrong.
That's just wrong.
Nobody's born with a
preference for video games.
You learn video games.
Nobody's born with a
preference for automobiles.
You learn about automobiles.
Most of our preferences
are learned.
And the way we learn--
the automobile's
a good example--
the way we learn depends
on our environment,
and if x is a big part
of the environment--
trees, cars, horses, dogs--
it will affect your preferences.
If you grew up with a dog in the
house, you probably like dogs.
If you didn't, you
may be ambivalent--
not that you're born loving
dogs are not loving dogs.
The environment matters.
So let me give you
another example.
There are a lot of examples.
Electricity gives
you an example.
This is another one of
his lovely pictures.
You start doing electricity--
he says, well, you develop
a regulatory system
that makes investment in
the electric power system
profitable.
When that's the case, you
develop a supplier network
that's selling
equipment into that--
to be invested.
As the grid network
gets bigger, it
becomes cheaper for
you to use electricity.
What's missing over here
are the appliance makers
that, once electricity's cheap,
begin to produce refrigerators,
and air conditioners,
and all kinds
of things that make electricity
more valuable-- dot, dot, dot.
You have equipment.
You have education.
You have lots of jobs tied up.
You have lots of habits
built around that system,
and it becomes hard to change.
Examples like this are
pretty easy to multiply.
If you think about air travel,
the better the airports,
the more attractive
air travel is.
The better the planes are, the
more attractive air travel is.
The greater the
demand for air travel,
the more you build
airports, the more
you invest in R&D in aircraft.
We have a whole legislative
structure around air travel.
We have a lot of training and
education around air travel.
There's all of these
investments that
make the system more attractive,
that make it grow, et cetera.
That's positive
interactions along the path.
Now, this is not evil stuff.
The fact that you
build better airports,
and you have better airplanes,
and the system works better--
this is not bad, but this means,
once you go down that path--
once you decide to do air,
rather than high-speed rail--
the air path is
self-reinforcing.
It'd be a little awkward in this
country, with our distances,
but you could
imagine [INAUDIBLE]
having decided
another path-- we're
going to do high-speed rail.
We get manufacturers
of those trains.
We've got people
laying the road bed.
building the stations.
It becomes more attractive to
travel by high-speed train.
And somebody says,
why would you use
airplanes along the East Coast?
Natural gas for heating-- you
get the same kind of story.
You drill wells.
You build pipelines.
You have laws.
You have regulations.
If you look at the US broadly,
our paths tend to be more
energy-intensive than the
paths in other rich countries--
fact-- not good, not bad-- fact.
But I will say there is a little
problem with Unruh's tone.
He calls this carbon lock-in.
It's not carbon lock-in.
It's path dependence.
It wouldn't be easy to move
away from bicycles in Amsterdam.
The city's kind
of built for them.
The streets are
laid out for them.
There are lots of repair shops.
They're available.
Everybody knows how to use them.
People can teach you
how to ride a bike.
All of those interactions are
true for the bicycle system
in Amsterdam.
It would not be
easy for them now.
Where would you part, if
you've been in that city?
Not easy to move away--
Beijing was built for
public transportation.
If you visit Beijing,
and if you're like me,
the first thing you
think of is, my God,
there's no place to part.
They have these huge
apartment buildings close
by each other-- very dense.
If all those people had cars,
where would you put them?
Now, they are moving
to the automobile path,
with some pain.
But once you go down that path,
which is a low-carbon path--
becomes harder to move off.
Similarly, London
or Paris, cities
that have subway networks,
that carry a lot of people--
lot of people use the subway.
It becomes politically
important to make it work well.
You begin to have a
workforce invested
in the subway, et
cetera, et cetera.
But you also have a
housing stock that's dense.
So if you say, well,
we're not going
to do mass transit anymore,
you have a problem.
Where are people going to park?
The roads aren't designed
to handle cars in quantity.
You can't move off
that path easily.
That's a low-carbon path.
Mass transit in Beijing
is a low-carbon path.
Bicycles in Amsterdam
are a low-carbon path.
So it's not just carbon lock-in.
It's path dependence.
It's, once you start
going down a path--
in some systems, not every
system you can think of--
but in some systems,
parts of the system
interact positively with
other parts of the system,
making it more and more
attractive and harder
and harder to leave.
OK so far?
So I hope I've convinced
you that you can never
change energy systems,
because that's wrong.
It has been done in
lots-- lots of times.
Clipper ships--
well, think about it.
You had people making sales.
You had designers.
You had shipyards.
And sailing technology you
can trace over the years.
Sailing technology got
better and better and better,
and carried more and more
commerce faster and faster.
So this was a path.
The whole world
was on that path.
That's gas light.
That's one of the last gas
lights in London being lit.
Streets used to be lit with gas.
Homes were too, but
particularly public areas
were illuminated at
night with gas lights.
That's a path.
You have people who learn
how to learn the technology.
You've invested in training.
You've invested in
the infrastructure
to get the gas there--
whole thing works.
People like light at night.
That is a coal-powered
locomotive
drawing a passenger train.
19th century-- locomotives
got better and better.
Railroads employed
a lot of people--
lot of fixed capital there.
Passenger trains went
from city to city.
I believe the locomotive
speed record in the US
was set in 1910.
At any rate, you had a
whole system built up--
coal-fired.
Coal-fired passenger
trains-- very important
intercity system.
And here's everybody's favorite.
This is Los Angeles in 1909.
Southern California had an
extraordinarily extensive set
of streetcars.
You could go anywhere.
If you've seen the movie
Roger Rabbit, where
the character says, who
needs a car in Los Angeles--
you ride these--
again, all the system
effects I talked
about are there.
You've got the
owners of the system.
You've got a large labor force.
It requires technology.
There's also a nice
network effect.
The more of these you
build, the more attractive
the whole system becomes.
So one route-- not so great.
Two routes-- better.
Three routes-- even
better, because you can
go lots of different places.
There are system effects.
All of those systems went away.
All of those systems, with all
of the same things I was just
talking about, went away.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Do you happen
to know how come it
happened that LA really
abandoned the whole care thing?
Was it something
specific or [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I
will tell you the story.
The story has a
couple of dimensions.
Sometimes it's just
something better comes along.
Steam turned out, after a lot
of R&D, to be better than sail.
The first steam
ships were lousy.
There's a lovely
museum in Munich
that actually lays
this out nicely.
The first steam
ships could basically
carry enough coal to make
it across the Atlantic
without much cargo.
They were very inefficient.
And efficiency really matters--
how efficient that engine
is, because it depends--
it determines how much
fuel you have to carry.
And if you have to carry a
lot of fuel to go someplace,
it's a lousy venture,
even though it gets there
much faster and more reliably.
So it took a lot of R&D.
Gas to electric lights--
that was a little quicker.
The arc light turned out to be
pretty good, and pretty early.
Coal to diesel locomotives--
well, that took a while.
The first diesel locomotives
appeared in the '20s,
and you really didn't have
diesel phased out for long haul
until the late '40s, '50s.
You had some diesel.
It took a while,
but it happened.
It happened.
So sometimes it took
changes in policy.
To really wipe
out the railroads,
you needed the interstate
highway system.
To get nuclear power,
you needed federal policy
to limit the liability
of nuclear plant owners.
You needed environmental policy
to really hit coal generation.
What happened in Los Angeles--
there are two stories.
The Los Angeles
streetcar network
was largely built by
real estate developers,
because it was a way of making
outlying properties more
valuable.
So the argument I've heard
is that Southern California
got sprawl before
it got automobiles,
because the idea was, we
can build streetcars out
to there, so they can
go from there downtown.
That makes that land valuable.
And the argument was
that's how they built it.
They overbuilt it, because this
was a land speculation game.
So they overbuilt it.
And then you had companies
that wanted to sell buses.
GM wanted to sell buses, so
GM lobbied to shut it down.
GM bought pieces of it.
Buses have advantages.
So eventually, the trolleys
got replaced by buses,
which got replaced by cars.
Again, you had ownership.
You had a system.
You had interactions
of various kinds.
The electric
companies, of course,
loved trolleys, because
they're low during the daytime.
One of the problems early
electric companies had
was all the demand was at night,
so you used your assets only
when it was dark.
Trolleys were great.
You could keep the whole
system running all day long.
So they loved them.
The people who worked
on them loved them.
The owners loved them.
They got beat out in part
because the systems were
overbuilt, in part
because buses had
certain operational advantages,
in part for political reasons.
It wasn't just Los Angeles.
You could travel
across a large part
of the country on trolleys,
and they went away everywhere--
mostly went away.
Old-- "old."
energy systems
can be displaced--
sometimes R&D, something
better comes along.
Sometimes changes in policy.
Sometimes both.
One of the problems
that, again, we
will look at in a number of
settings as we go forward
is the so-called
chicken egg problem.
So suppose you wanted
to say, gee, natural gas
is a better transportation
fuel than oil--
right now it's a lot cheaper,
and we have a lot of it here--
well, I'm not going
to buy a natural gas
car unless I can fill it, unless
there are places I can refuel.
And I'm not going to have a
natural gas filling station
unless there are cars.
That's a chicken egg problem.
You need them both, and nobody's
going to invest in one side
unless there's some assurance
that you're going to get
investment in the other side.
You don't build fancy
airplanes for passenger
travel unless
there are airports,
but why would you
invest in an airport
unless people are going to use
it to travel on fancy planes?
So most of these systems
had chicken egg problems.
Automobiles are pretty
useless without good roads,
but why would you
build good roads
unless there's going
to be a lot of traffic?
So most new systems
faced this problem.
Oh, yeah, you-- why did Edison
invent the electric light?
Well, Edison invented the
electric light because,
without a reliable
electric light,
what was the point of
generating electricity?
There'd be no market for it.
So without a light,
there's no market
for electricity in the 1880s.
So he needed to do both.
If he was going to do something,
he had to do the system.
He had to have the
generator and the bulb--
useless without each
other, without the other.
So a lot of these new systems
face chicken egg problems,
but one of the
things we're going
to talk about on and off is
replacing energy systems,
and how that might happen.
You see some obstacles.
This last slide is intended
to point out to you
that they are not forever.
Energy systems will change.
Coal-fired power
plants will not be
a major part of this country's
energy system in 2100.
You can probably bet
good money on that--
nothing like the ones we have.
But getting there will
take a little work.
And who knows-- maybe
gasoline-powered automobiles
won't either.
OK, questions, comments,
reactions, thoughts?
You're on today.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You can't get an A just
from participation.
I just want you to know that.
OK.
It's all good, but--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question
regarding developing countries.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One thing
I was thinking
while you were speaking is,
at some point, you need to--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: They
need to make choices and get
on paths.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
Because if you want, you can
perpetuate everything back
to cavemen and everything
[INAUDIBLE] some sort
of [INAUDIBLE] so
it's quite hard to--
so I was just thinking it's
for [INAUDIBLE] developing
countries, One is when
they make a choice--
having spoken about
everything today,
it's that very often
I feel that there's
this narrow-minded--
after what we spoke
about the cost-benefit analysis
[INAUDIBLE] in the sense
that you might say,
OK, a natural gas power
plant is more expensive than
a coal one, so let's go ahead
and build a coal power
plant [INAUDIBLE]
build coal power plants.
But you go down a path
which you may not--
that you should definitely
take into account--
you might build some
sort of expertise
in something and everything
that we talk about.
So that's one thing,
and I'm not sure
if it's done at all in
developing countries.
And the other thing is, in
theory, given that you're--
if you think [INAUDIBLE] a
blank check have no [INAUDIBLE]
dependance, wouldn't
it makes sense
to see that whatever choice is
made by these sort of countries
is the most optimal,
given what they've
seen with other countries?
So if I'm a country
that has nothing--
I have no universal health
care, so-- and I see all these
models, I say, which
one's the best,
of course for my conditions,
but wouldn't that--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
You're making two points.
Let me just respond briefly,
and then I'll let everybody go.
Sometimes you do
have a clean slate.
I remember a visit to Kyoto--
no, Nagoya.
I was actually in
the government,
and I was being walked
around by a local official.
And I was commenting
on how attractive
the broad boulevards and
squares they had were.
And he looked at me and he said,
well, there was nothing here,
so we could design a city.
You don't feel good when you've
just walked into one of those.
But sometimes that's true.
The Cambodians, for instance--
you got imported oil to
generate your electricity.
You're burning wood.
You have a relatively
clean slate,
and you can decide what to do,
but the other side of the coin
is you have a lot of
really poor people.
China's not building
coal-fired power plants
because they're not thinking
about tomorrow at all.
They're balancing
tomorrow against today.
They have hundreds of millions
of wretchedly poor people
still.
Do I want to make my
grandchildren better off,
or do--
their grandchildren
better off, or do I
want to make them
better off now?
That's not an easy choice.
And a responsible government
will wrestle with it,
but you don't always--
the answer isn't
always to put yourself
on the path that looks
best in a century.
They're trying to do the
right thing, I believe,
but figuring out what the
right thing is is not trivial.
Anybody else?
OK.